la sphère des dîners de pierre jean
chalon sont prend une dimension
politique considérable
la question politique la plus importante
du moment alors que le mercredi nous
recevions sûreté pmp bruno serveur lors
de la soirée du 1er avril au palais
vivienne qui a affirmé avoir aperçu un
représentant politique ce soir-là peux
pas vous dire autre chose que cette
personne qui a des cheveux gris hier
soir c'est 20 sont médecins de la soirée
qui a apporté sa version et elle est
toute autre et en aucun cas je n'ai vu
du membre du gouvernement qui témoigne
âge qui diffère alors y at il vraiment
eu dîner ou non combien de personnes
étaient présentes et des hommes
politiques on kiffe vraiment enfreint le
protocole sanitaire qui y est allé
domicile du chef christophe leroy et le
palais qui viennent ont été
perquisitionnés afin d'y trouver des
preuves vierge en chalencon quant à lui
a été interpellé par la police
judiciaire
ce soir bruno pomart nous dit tout ce
qui s'est passé ces dernières 24 heures
alors pierre jean chalon sont donc a été
placé en garde à vue aujourd'hui merci
bruno pomart d'être avec no mercy
mont-bruno donc ex-policier instructeur
du raid il ay la saison très partout un
bruno pomart et bien sûr on a des
nouvelles des nouvelles données sur
cette affaire alors hier pierre jean
salençon a été entendu toute la journée
par la police qui est normal ouais voilà
donc c'est normal c'est on va revoir les
images bien sûr d'hier quand il a été
voir là il a été interpellé par la
police
merci beaucoup
perquisition ça
au lycée la dpj ont dit d'accord partie
à la préfecture de police on sait barre
comment ça c'est un concert avec un
numéro
donc ça c'est la perquisition mais je
veux voir aussi et pierre-jean chalencon
on voit ensuite il est amené à la dpj
à paris la préfecture de police ac les
images exclusives de chez jean-marc nous
les a passés jean marc morandini et
c'est vrai qu'il ait donc il est
interpellé car c'est normal
oui c'était pour ces dures que ce serait
et mine de rien on va pas se mentir
c'est l'impressionnant les mecs a estimé
jean edouard à tous les types toutes les
personnes satine ma chérie ça c'est
impressionnant là franchement je trouve
ça impressionnant dans le sens ça prend
c'est vrai énormément de proportions
c'est ça sauvera il faut pas se cacher
il ya aussi beaucoup de gars en fait
deux soirées clandestines des choses
comme ça oui c'est un peu j'avais un
côté quand même très politique à cette
version
c'est là où c'est le même c'est parce
que on parle tous de cet homme politique
qui serait allé à cette soirée
tout le monde le cherche le trac nous
les donnons à céline quoi vous l'avez
vous mais non pour la lionne il ya des
noms il ya des noms mais deux députés
aux patients de décéder je vous le dis
c'était et les plus il ya un autre
dossier sur des restaurants clandestins
comme nous l'ont dit noan idem si c'est
nos amis de nos quotidiens
concernant deux hommes politiques assez
connus qui aurait été apparemment dans
des restaurants clandestins mais ça
c'est un autre dossier
voilà ça c'est un autre dossier sur le
dossier du palais vivienne
on parle de députés bruno pomas et c'est
pour ça que ça prend une ampleur
incroyable a évidemment ses connotations
politiques en plus touché des membres du
gouvernement soi disant attention alors
n'ont alors rien de ce qu'on sait mieux
pour les sens on a série est vraiment
drôle de devoir démarrer l'air beaucoup
plus du banc des infos qu'on connaît je
vous le dis il n'y a pas de membres du
gouvernement bernard montiel
non c'est sûr il ya aucun membre du
gouvernement ce sera député ministre ni
ministre ni secrétaire d'état ni quoi
que ce soit ce serait vraiment aller
lire été décalé rejeté grave un député
sur com
juridiquement on peut rien lui fait
alors que député s'était lui donc on
peut prendre beaucoup que sont bruno
pomart donc hier et est interpellé
pierre-jean chalencon il est entendu par
là par la police judiciaire
qu'est ce qui s'est dit vous avez
enquêté qu'est ce qu'est ce qui s'est
passé il ya tout simplement il est
entendu surtout ce qu'il toutes les
déclarations qu'il a faites à l'endroit
et à l'envers puisqu'il a dit tout et
n'importe quoi donc ça intéresse
évidemment les enquêteurs de savoir ce
qui s'est réellement passé par rapport à
l'éventuelle présence de ministres qui
n'est pas le cas effectivement mais deux
personnalités politiques ça c'est
important que tous les côtés vite s'ils
étaient huit comme il a dit une fois ou
quarante six étaient jusqu'à 17h30
jusqu'à 22h30
il était très maladroit surtout donc la
d 1 kg et or de la pj donc l'ont
convoqué ce matin il est venu erik son
avocat a mis en garde à vue ce qui est
normal dans la procédure d'inquiets toc
l'avait mis en garde à vue oui c'est non
c'est normal qu'ils sont sûrs de
l'accouplement de rejoindre celle que
l'on puisse ce que me disent les
téléspectateurs c'est que hier en fait
il a été entendu il a été relâché
aujourd'hui ils ont été le chercher pour
mettre en garde à vue en france et que
quand il avait été relâché hier
non non c'est que la non non le parquet
le parquet a ordonné sûrement la
convocation donc et il est venu avec son
avocat ce matin donc il a droit à 24
heures de garde à vue qui peut être
prolongée le parquet peut prolonger de
24 heures depuis c'est à dire 48 heures
compte tenu du contexte et compte tenu
du personnage sulfureux que représente
ce monsieur et qui met en porte à faux
le gouvernement savait que le
gouvernement a quand même plein de
problèmes à gérer depuis depuis quelques
temps avec l'affairé covit ça n'avait
justement je pense le ministre intérieur
c'est un fait dans cette histoire on l'a
vu gérald darmanin a réagi jean castex a
réagi je sais que le chef de l'état est
également sur cette affaire gabriela
talent paul par la grille elle étale le
porte parole du gouvernement aussi est
sur le dossier tout le gouvernement est
mobilisé
on peut le dire aujourd'hui bruno pomart
c'était pas un membre du gouvernement
qui avait dansé n'auront pas
nécessairement non jesson faire la quête
pour une fois
gardons du recul même si bernard année
sur moi j'ai des éléments qui dit que
effectivement c'est pas un membre du
gouvernement
c'est en présentant un représentant de
la république qui était présent
attendons que la sphère passe aussi
ayant encore un peu plus les marges
parce que les 24 heures de garde à vue
peut-être les 48 heures vont donner des
éléments supplémentaires à la quête de
ce que de ce que vous nous dites vous
êtes en train de dire que peut-être
pierre-jean chalencon hier lorsqu'il a
en temps et est entendu par la pj
il aurait donner plus d'éléments la
police judiciaire et qu'il aurait
peut-être donner le nom du député ou
d'un homme politique est ce qu'il a
donné à la police il a tout il a tout
intérêt
vous savez il nous la vérité est ce
qu'il l'abonné ou pas formulé nouioui il
ya des oui oui oui c'est la donnée de
rawbank été donnée aux enquêteurs faire
aimer de la pj comme on dit qu'ils ont
fait c'est ça ton qui hier père jean
chalencon devant la police judiciaire
il n'a pas la balance il a il a dit la
vérité oui mais ce matin ce matin ça va
être l'élément importante de la delà de
la garde à vue c'est que là il ya le la
justice et qui est vraiment saisit de la
sphère totalement et pour pouvoir
capitaliser un maximum d'éléments sur
cette infraction parce que c'est quand
même une infraction grave ça va clasher
pas mal de choses derrière je pense à
une fermeture administrative en
l'occurrence de son bien sûr son
établissement ce qu'elle mériterait
largement puisque on le fait pour des
plus petits et pour des gens qui ont
fait beaucoup moins de choses donc je
pense qu'il mérite au risque et je
rassure tout le monde le nom on va
forcément sortir oui le monde va parler
de ce que nous dit et la sarthe et en ce
que vient de nous dire bruno pomart de
ce que vous venez nous dire mono pomas
il aurait donné il aurait dit toute la
vérité
mais il a dit tout et tirez vous savez
les vous avez jamais eu affaire à la pj
aurait dit oui à la paix notre méthode
vrai nom la pj je vous assure et se sont
de fait limiers et sachez que lorsqu ils
vous prennent en main c'est pas bon
généralement il vous faut parler ah
ouais et il est et il est tournée tout
honneur il est entendu par combien de
personnes il ya au moins de trois
enquêteurs
évidemment qui se relaient qui le font
comme il a quand même une façon de sa de
se parler qui est quand même assez
désopilante sait plus où il va donner
quel sens ira donc au bout d'un moment
il arrive à remettre tout ça en ordre et
puis il ya trouvé les éléments qu'il
faut pour pourvoir les inculpés ou tout
au moins ne pas dire construire les
fractions tête de ce que vous savez est
ce que il a avoué qu'ils étaient
quarante personnes ou est ce qu'il est
pour lui ils sont tous les étés toujours
neuf pas d'information là-dessus la
corporation des informations ce qui se
passe c'est que après la perquisition
ils ont trouvé des documents et
notamment un document qui met en
difficulté la défense de pierre-jean
chalencon et christophe leroy parce
qu'on a la preuve qu'ils avaient le 1er
avril
regardez le roi ce club c'est christophe
leroy de 1er avril ouaip à lévis
viennent
220 euros par personne donc les
enquêteurs ils ont ce document donc
maintenant ils leur disent il y avait
donc une soirée il y avait donc un
échange monétaire outre il y avait et il
sont obligés de parler sinon ils vont
tomber plus lourdement avait là les
langues se délient avec ce document et
les enquêteurs ont tout maintenant alors
qu'on se resserre jean marc morandini ce
matin est revenu sur la perquisition
pearl en chalencon aura d'autres infos
bien sûr de bruno pomart dans un instant
une personne qui était à l'intérieur du
parc du palais vivienne lors de la
perquisition a livré un témoignage
exclusif à jean-marc dans son émission
regardée
il a raconté ce qui s'était passé il ya
un peu près une dizaine de policiers qui
sont arrivés avec mallette une mallette
s'apparentaient à des policiers de la
police scientifique ils sont arrivés
devant la porte
elles viennent de policiers est rentré
et apparemment ils ont pris des
empreintes et puis vers 18h ya un peu
près huit policiers
là la police judiciaire qui sont allés
voir une dame qui habite au deuxième et
donc du coup ils lui ont expliqué que il
voulait pas faire sortir puis en
revanche alençon par par devant parce
que devant il y avait plein de
journalistes et non du coup il fallait
le faire sortir par une de petite porte
dérobée alors oui si c'est sûr c'est que
le gouvernement prend cette affaire très
au sérieux parce que son image a quand
même été écornée dans cette histoire et
qu'a priori il n'y aurait pas eu deux
ministres dans ces dîners donc la gamme
vie politique sont nés chez pierre en
chalencon ils ont pris son téléphone
aussi donc et puis depuis hier 17 heures
pierre vengeance on n'a plus de
téléphone
ils ont regardé ses messages ses
conversations pour voir les éventuels
échanges avec des politiques ou des
personnalités importantes et on a le
sentiment un peu qui veut lui faire
payer est ce qu'on peut comprendre parce
que leur image a été très écornée quand
même sens on marie parlant cette affaire
je sais que tout le monde en parle dans
le gouvernement tout le monde parce que
même les ministres entre eux sachez le
ce 10è ce qu'il y avait vraiment un
ministre ou pas est-ce qu'il y avait un
montage d'événements ou pas il m'est
même entre eux et je vous le dis c'est
comme vous savez si ce jeu de quand on
fait le jeu du loup garou c'est à dire
que tout le monde se dit le loup garou
c'est peut-être lui c'est peut-être plus
est réduit et apparemment c'est vrai qu'
il n'y aurait pas eu deux ministres
là-bas ce serait un député comme on le
dit vous le dis les républicains
justement bruno pomart c'est ça qui a
fait qui a mis le feu aux poudres
parce que quand on voit mine de rien
cette arrestation
cette perquisition on se dit c'est quand
même lourd c est ce que c'est pas
disproportionnée par rapport aux faits
et est ce que il n'y a pas eu quand même
c'est vrai que cette histoire qui a pris
ses qui est devenue une affaire d'état
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on voit des images
extrêmement voilà qui sont violentes
c'est pas très dur
sinon même toit le boisseau garde ceux
qui m'aiment bien ou c'est pas ça c'est
certain
challans sommet en attendant l'affairé
tellement grave est qu effectivement
tous les enquêteurs son nom mais
pourquoi les granulés pantillon elle est
noble éthique vous pour pourquoi les
graphes ce n est pas tout simplement
parce que l'époux place clément député
mais un député un moment donné on a dit
qu'il y avait un ministre et ça c'est
pour le gouvernement c'est terrible
parce que le gouvernement prendrait des
salles de tous les sens avec la ferc aux
vidéos et donc ils sont très inquiets
donc trouvé son intérieur je sais que
vous connaissez bien le ministère de
l'intérieur connaissait bien les
légendes du ministère un terrain qu'est
ce qui vous dit sur cette affaire bah
c'est surtout que le ministre intérieur
il est remonté comme une pendule
donc il faut absolument savoir la vérité
sur cette affaire ce qui est normal
c'est pour ça qu'il a fait il a prescrit
dit-il ou qu'il avait là une garde à vue
comment c'est lui qui a demandé la garde
à vue mardi
il s'est d'ailleurs les services
enquêteurs c'est eux qui décident avec
des éléments doit mettre en garde à vue
quelques restaurateurs aussi derrière
tout le monde qui est fermée qu'elle
respecte les lois et puis fin parce
qu'il veut tout à fait il me semble
qu'il ya eu des manifestations
citoyennes des éléments que l'affairé
j'ai ce qui risque aujourd'hui s'il y
avait vraiment 40 personnes à cette
soirée
s'ils avaient bon c'est pas qui voit là
y'avait mais s'il n'y avait pas de
distance de sécurité s'il n'y avait pas
s'ils l'ont pas respecté les règles
strictes de lourdes amendes possibles de
la prison et surtout fait remarquer
administrative on parle d'un an de
prison
il ne fera pas c'est plus parce que la
cc place et oui c'est une personne
morale c'est pas et donc ses cinq ans
oui c'était un accent et 75000 euros on
te bannir ça ne passera pas au saban des
fermetures administratives c'est le pire
que peut avoir un établissement donc
c'est là qu'est ce qui va se passer pour
père jean chalencon procédure classique
donc 24e gardois de garde a peut-être -
ou peut-être plus il a fait les 24
heures de garde à vue c'est parce
qu'elle a commencé ce matin pourquoi il
a fait les 24 heures de des gars de
garde à vue après
arrêtez entendu c'est que ce qu'il a dit
aux enquêteurs ne leur convenait pas où
il en a pas dit assez il en a 10 trous
ils ont considéré que ce qu'il avait dit
pouvait leur permettre de le mettre en
garde à ses c'est tout ce que vous dites
et en même temps ça fait des relevés
avec la police scientifique qui est très
très efficace d'ailleurs un autre d'un
autre dans notre ministère
des relevés d'identité des relevés dans
l'environnement direct du l'endroit où
ils habitent parce que quand les
indicateurs se déploie ils sont arrivés
en nombre
on interroge tout moment mettre tous les
gens qui passent fois son prix est
systématiquement et ensuite
mais sur ces éléments avérés est ce qu
ont récupéré dans les inquiétudes de la
police scientifique effectivement tout
ça revient à la pj et puis à partir de
ce matin il a été convoqué donc pour
être mis en examen sûrement est en garde
à vue garde à vue et mise en examen mais
paraît qu'ils enquêtent aussi sur le
financement du palais viviane de terre
une enquête élargie autour du palais
river la main mais tout va être il va
être y va être épluchés va être
déshabillé comme je l'étais si riche que
ça ce bonhomme pour avoir un palais
comme ça donc il avait 6 millions
d'euros là mais d'où vient l'argent
simon est justement d'autres capitaux
que les siens alors oui alors gilles
verdez ils vont essayer de faire toute
la transparence et comme ils ont saisi
plein de documents
il ya une grande vulnérabilité
maintenant est effectivement pour qu'il
soit entendu le soir et le lendemain
c'est qu'entre les deux il en a pas d
assez donc on va lui dire maintenant
voilà senna et la syrie l'option la
garde à vue se mettre la pression
paris il faut pas être dupe vous avez
tout à fait raison si c'est aussi invite
aussi fort c'est parce que y'a pas des
consignes directe du gouvernement mais
peu et voilà les ministères ils disent
je vais évidemment parce que riz daïf la
valérie bédard a dit le président
il est naïf la comprends pas qu'on va
arrêter ça jamais été aussi vite
moi je vous dis que ne me dites pas
qu'il ya pas le ministre de l'intérieur
quatre afin de régler cette affaire
rapidement et en quoi c'est dû renoncer
parce que les formations va tellement
vite et vous le savez oui même le
minisite et rien ne va pas s'amuser à
appeler la dpj allah vous m'occuper mais
ça fait ils ont la pression du ministre
non ce n'est pas ta garde à vue je ne le
permettrai pas parce que des mots fusent
de partout maintenant être le ministre
va pas s'amuser à faire ça les
inquiétudes à pj ils ont des ordres il
ya une effraction tout simplement non
civiles et moi on est passés spéciaux du
gouvernement mais un moment mais c'est
une affaire nous c'est que le
gouvernement est énervé c'est normal si
on les a mis dans une sauce qui n'était
pas la leur donc forcément ça n'existait
pas nous on a tellement de son ca gérer
on se retrouve dans une sauce en plus ce
qui n'est pas la nôtre à cause de voilà
de cette soirée donc forcément ils sont
énervés ils veulent faire toute la
lumière sur cette affaire pour pouvoir
dire dans quelques jours employés nous
on n'avait rien à voir la passion si
c'est pour ça que là on est parti d'une
soirée qui sont devenus des soirées
blanquette aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est
de savoir s'il ya eu lors de ces soirées
des ministres je vous rappelle juste une
chose c'est que m6 a confirmé la
présence d'un ministre lors d'une soirée
au palais wynants
des bêtises soirée de fous vous dis des
bêtises arrêter tu plais vraiment
n'importe quoi
vous dites n'importe quoi nicolas
pernikoff m6 a dit je te le dis nicolas
je t'aime beaucoup mais là tu dis des
bêtises il ya la soirée du palais vivier
voilà oui il y avait un homme politique
ce serait un 17e minute les républicains
et il ya d'autres restaurants
clandestins qui se trouveraient dans le
6e arrondissement où il n'est pas le
palin vienne où il y aurait peut-être là
un membre du gouvernement qui serait
allé c'est ce qu'a dit m cissé volicon
sa toile à ça d'avoir ces deux jours
seront différentes avez raison c'est que
immédiatement darmanin fait déclaration
dès le départ amusant si un ministre qui
démissionnera des soient sanctionnés de
ce rite
oui il faut rappeler qu'elle porte
parole du gouvernement il faut rappeler
également que quand christophe leroy est
également en garde à vue ce matin
étaient convoqués aussi la pj il faut
dire qu'alors lui risque à trois ans
d'emprisonnement 45000 euros d'amendé
pour travail dissimulé et jusqu'à un an
de prison et 15000 euros d'amendé pour
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui il est
déjà papa il est déjà mal en point
ouais mais le seul qui rien dans cette
histoire c'est le député en fait dans sa
bulle il est vrai qu'il a raison il a
une immunité l'ue d'aider à diminuer le
risque rien si le dernier l'ancienne
c'est à dire que toute cette affaire ses
nombreux députés un canton à savoir le
non dit des critères le gard on sait
qu'il a des cheveux gris
je vous laisse il ya un gars qui fait
une teinture la d'équipé une teinture
dans les trois jours on sait que c'est
lui non mais d'éviter à bah oui c'est
sûr mais sachez que mis à part la
pression
ainsi par rapport à celle ci pourra pas
démissionner et de l'assam et nationale
va pas faire une levée non aujourd'hui
levé luminet l'immunité en voyage bonobo
marqué ce qui va se passer donc
maintenant garde à vue dont les 2/3 de
46 24 si le parquet ne décide s'ils
veulent aller un peu plus et je le
mettrais sur les téléspectateurs le nom
du député on le saura à mon avis ce
week-end là ça va être dans les
prochaines heures je vais fouine et je
vous dirai ça voilà il a il l'a donnée
par jean en son nom il a donné du tabac
ça va être des négociations tout ça
évidemment les encore une fois les
enquêteurs sur là pour ça il a dit
évidemment il droit ils ont ils ont des
informations ils ont les informations
donc là forcément lundi ça va sortir
mais très très vite donc on saura leur
nom ce député willy bernard montiel non
le député ne risque rien son vis-à-vis
de ses électeurs c'est tout mais pascal
ac il fait alors l'assemblée nationale
peut s'en saisir et c'est déjà arrivé
par le passé en le canon sais pas quand
mais justement bfm tv a eu
pierre-jean chalencon à la sortie il se
fait lui un avant qui repartent en garde
à vue regardez ils ont une petite
intervention du genre de pierre-jean
chance
non jamais
je parle pas de rigoler quand le mur
la pression et je vais combien je
suggérais innocent passé chalencon qui
dit ça prend des proportions démesurées
mais c'est vrai que ça il devrait se
terminer
oui vous trouvez ben oui c'est lui qui
déclenche tout ça j'aurais pas parler de
ministre je pense doit cesser bien sûr
il faisait sa soirée klein décide à la
limite et plus des clashs et les la
réplique de vouloir être ouvrier on
brûle un oui guillaume suis d'accord
gouvernement a mis la pression pour que
cette affaire soit réglée vite et de
manière assez son récent des milliers
ils ont raison mais alors vrai est ce
que pour ce type d'infraction c'est pas
un peu beaucoup dix policiers
cette pression déclare un peu de
scénariser en vrai franchement bien sûr
sur des opérations lorsque la pj et se
déplacer ils sont maintenant il ya dix
policiers pour la journée la socialiste
d'après les scientifiques il ya des
enquêteurs il ya ceux qui font
l'environnement direct du lieu où on
était relié donc ça oui ça m'intéresse
viennent pas d'eux comme ça oui moi
sincèrement je pense que même sans ce
délai aux deux ministres l'histoire
aurait quand même pris de l'ampleur vu
qu'il s'agit de dîners clandestins de
soirée clandestinement ce pas je pense
que autant d'ampleur mais ça on aurait
quand même prix et tous les policiers je
trouve que c'est pas trop parce que tout
le monde en fait et forcément tout un
plat moi je trouve que c'est beaucoup
trop haut mais j'aurais pas bien sur wii
vierge en chalencon c'était un citoyen
qui a fait une soirée clandestine comme
certains ont déjà fait forcément en un
an et demi forcément mes enfants il un
vol qui devient le bouc émissaire parce
qu'on veut absolument taper sur la
politique ministre et lui sept points
des proportions donc le défi le député
ne sera pas puni et lui sera puni à la
passe qu'il est dans une dans un trou
des politiques afin de ressembler voilà
je vous dise enfin merci gilles verdez
c'est une affaire d'état au conseil des
ministres mercredi emmanuel macron on a
parlé je suis un appel a dit à la sortie
oui le président il a demandé en séries
bernard à tous ces milices vous y étiez
ou pas à vous rendre les acca une
question d'éthique le gouvernement de se
positionner
oui mais avoir une chance sur bruno
pomart le gouvernement si nous on a les
infos le gouvernement les a ils savent
très bien qu elle ait pas de ministre
mine de rien aujourd'hui à 99
fusée d'information en chalencon sa
foutue le bassin oui notre nation ufvn
la vérité il me le dira mais c'était pas
nous c'est les républicains à l'arrêt ou
je sais pas mais chalencon lui-même
avait dit qu'il n'y avait pas de
ministres ni de membres du gouvernement
et même le chef christophe leroy l'a dit
aussi douce est sorti alors certains
stands mais c'est chalon ici qu'à
l'issue des matchs sinon c'est bon il
s'est vanté c'est tout il sait quand et
si elle sait vraiment si oui le serveur
qui était chez nous mais le serveur qui
était chez nous je voulais dit il
en fait et quoi x était un membre du
gouvernement on lui a montré je voulais
dit tout trombino s'est alarmé un membre
du gouvernement ministre lida d'état il
a reconnu personne n'y connaît rien à la
politique
alors voilà il nous l'a dit lui-même et
en fait on a on l'interrogeait après on
a compris que c'était un député en fait
voilà et on sait pour apparemment ce
serait les républicains ce que nous dira
voilà bernard montiel mais je vous le
dis le nom on l'aura là ce week-end dans
le sort à bruno pomart vous me le dirait
qu'ils sont ce week end chose ap le même
dimanche on bâille plaisir je reste il
faut savoir dans ce type d'un kg est
aussi c'est que le problème serait tout
un tas de gens qui s'improvisent comcom
injures et là dedans c'est celle des
éléments et qui perturbent l'inquiéter
ça parce que ça me donne derrière un
serviteur tu l'as vu mais je n'ai pas vu
mes
[Rires]